northern california's fierce
fiercest wildfire rather is getting
closer to lake tahoe threatening
thousands of homes around that popular
tourist destination
caldor fire is still mostly out of
control roads leading out of the area
near the nevada border were jam-packed
yesterday with cars just trying to get
out of there ann makovic of our san
francisco station k picks has more from
near south lake tahoe
the fast-moving caldor fire raced toward
the popular resort town of south lake
tahoe monday last night massive flames
were seen on a highway about five miles
from town the wind whipped fire exploded
in size over the past two days
destroying several homes and part of a
ski resort popular during tahoe's winter
season crews used snow making equipment
to try to fight the flames
due to the smoke conditions we're not
able to fly aircraft it's limited our
ability to bring all of our tools to the
fight
those forced to evacuate on monday faced
bumper to bumper traffic with many
roadways closed because of the fire
mel smothers played his violin to pass
the time and sarah ellis had little time
to hit the road have to leave most of
our belongings behind and just take the
important step the town's main medical
facility also proactively evacuated more
than four dozen patients
the fire reaching tahoe would be
potentially catastrophic on par with the
destruction seen in the town of paradise
in 2018. tahoe exists in a very high
fire hazard severity zone meaning it is
especially vulnerable to wildfires
officials say the drought coupled with
climate change are changing the very
vocabulary of california's wildfires
historically we've used the terms such
as anomaly
unprecedented or extreme these terms are
no longer appropriate
and one reason south lake tahoe is so
vulnerable to fires is because just a
few blocks from the glitz and glamour of
the casinos here at state line is these
tiny little neighborhoods that have
older homes and logged cabins that would
just go up like a matchstick if this
fire does reach town also the u.s
forestry service has closed all u.s
forests in california because of the
high fire danger back to you
all right ann thank you very much